[Music]
so you tell me after 21 years at this
label if I don't open for your little
aunjanue who wouldn't make it as one of
my backup singers that you're not gonna
support me those are your words not mine
but still I need to know your decision
[Music]
well you can kiss my decision as it's
walking out the door I think she's
saying kiss my buttocks
Connie Britton was nominated for an Emmy
and a Golden Globe for her role as
country star that's Rayna James in the
hit show Nashville I love that show
Britton is known for a versatile
performances she played a football
coaches wife on Friday Night Lights
remember that the mother of a demon baby
in American Horror Story an emergency
dispatcher on the drama 9-1-1 well she
returns now as a guest star in the new
season of Showtime's comedy series milf
the show follows Bridgette she's a
single mom struggling to give her son a
better life and Connie Britton portrays
Bridget's boss listen to this
description Allie rich and self-consumed
stay-at-home mom today's my birthday
happy birthday what are you doing
tonight are you are you celebrating
why you won't have dinner Oh amazing
that's really our dinner oh that would
be so fun yeah I can't tonight I'm
actually supposed to have a date but no
one can watch Larry oh I also can stay
with him yeah LC will do it just come to
dinner with me and then go on your date
oh really yeah she won't care oh no she
won't care she doesn't anything else to
do she can do it okay and then I'll go
see Hank quite a hoots milf Arizona time
that's a division by the way of CBS and
Connie Britton aka Ali joins us at the
table good to see you thank you give
good mom but let's talk about Ali
because he's so how do you describe her
cuz you watch her she's annoying but
she's very entertaining we were just
talking about earlier it is fun you know
I love to play powerful women but it's
also with this character it
fun to kind of go into the dark side you
know it's sort of it's sort of how I
sometimes think of her as who who I who
I feel like when I'm on my work when I'm
on the worst day what I mean yes and on
the show you know we I look at this
character as somebody who gave up a lot
she gave up she which she was a very
successful lawyer she had all these
dreams about what she was going to
accomplish she gave it up to get married
and to have money and to be a mother and
she's angry all the characters have
issues and all the characters on the
show that's something that's really
important to the creator of the show
Frankie Shaw all of the characters are
flawed and you know they're trying to be
kind of real explorations into what it
is the complexities of being a woman I
love human I love what one critic said
about your character so they wrote she
is every white lady who has ever cut in
front of you at Whole Foods and then
went on to say Britain is not in every
episode but I wish she were she brings
tremendous depth to a character that
could easily have been a one-dimensional
joke so when you get a script like does
it really say that when you get a script
like this how do you see that I mean how
do you recognize a character that's that
you can do that with well when I got
this script I was blown away by how what
different storytelling it was and what
what ambitious storytelling it was and
it is and and I hadn't heard a voice
like Frankie Shaw's voice Frankie who
created the show I hadn't heard a voice
like that for women really before and
you know it just felt like an exciting
area to go into because I am interested
as much as I love to play powerful
empowered women and I actually believe
that all women are always trying to
empower themselves but I'm also
interested in the things that keep us
from finding that power and its really
interesting to explore that in
characters and I saw that in this show
and given that you've played so many of
these powerful women how's this
character different
well she is somebody who is living much
more in the victimization of her own
flaws and of her own traumas you know
and the choices that she's made she now
feels like a victim to her own choices
and that's an interesting thing it's a
it's an interesting psychology but I
think also something that might be very
relatable to more women than you realize
you know and I think we're at a time
right now where as women and men we're
really looking at ourselves and it's
smart because for those who don't know
what MILF means google it we can't say
it yeah well it changes every week
that's it I'm losing faith surrogate
mothers and Spira loving families and
then there was a traditional thing that
you North said you have to Google she's
right about that let's talk about
Frankie Shaw for just a second because
there have been some issues on the set
The Hollywood Reporter recently
described a production plagued by
allegations of abusive behavior and
violations of industry rules
specifically calling out Frankie Shaw
that she reportedly pressured an actress
into a nude scene despite her no nudity
clause what can you tell us about that
in your experience on the set well
Frankie has a just addressed it we
should say yeah I to me I I was really
surprised to hear those things because I
can only speak for my experience with
Frankie and on the set of the show and
we're not on the set for that when those
incidents occurred by the way no and and
in fact I have a very different
experience of being on that set I find
the set to be incredibly collaborative
and there's a really strong sense of
mutual respect amongst everybody the
cast and the crew alike and you know I
think Frankie has an amazing work ethic
well your performance is terrific Connie
Britton and your roommate was curious
and Gillibrand
[Laughter]
you